So here we have a sample of cobalt. Now I
have got lots and
lots of different samples of cobalt in my
drawer, so this is
cobalt sponge.
Cobalt is, in many ways, similar to iron.
It can form magnets.
So this cobalt has been generated from a solution
and it’s
been made in very, very finely dispersed so
it has a very large
surface area. It’s very good for doing catalytic
reactions.
The magnets that you use in colour televisions,
for the loud
speakers, contain cobalt. You need to use
cobalt in the
magnets in the colour television or the old
sort of colour
television not the ones with LCD screens because
the
magnetic fields from larger magnets could
affect the electron
guns and so spoil the colours so you need
a very small
magnet on your loud speaker or the colours
all go funny.
Cobalt sponge absorbs lots and lots of gas
for perhaps
hydrogenation.
Many years ago, in the 1970s, when there was
a civil war in
Africa in the region Katanga where cobalt
is mined, there was
a shortage of cobalt and the production of
colour televisions
stopped for some considerable time until the
production
restarted.
So you can see it flows in the bottle. So
I have another
sample of cobalt and that is simply a foil.
So again that is a
very nice malleable tin-type foil; very, very
good structures.